alright guys bangbang parker's back for
round two
thank you do this man absolutely good to
be back then crab me on for sure so for
anyone who didn't listen to the first
episode we've recorded maybe let's just
start with kind of a two minutes on your
background and what you've done before
you got to Unchained yeah absolutely
so yeah historically my background has
been traditional financial services to
started out working for Deutsche Bank in
around the financial crisis then when
did a stint in restructuring creditor
side restructuring work out type work
helping him manage companies through
bankruptcies and then coming out of
bankruptcy then ended up going and
working for a hedge fund in Dallas Texas
called Heyman capital run by the best
friend named Kyle bass and it was really
there when I started to dig in on the
Fed understand global macro and
independent from that I was also doing
work on Bitcoin and you know through the
course of 2016-2017 really doing a deep
dive on on the Fed and understanding I
was attempting to understand what would
happen when the Fed began to unwind its
balance sheets and where that logically
brought me back to was the financial
crisis and understanding QE how could
you understand what would happen when
the Fed unwounded balance sheet if you
didn't know what was what cue it
actually was and through that process I
was also learning about Bitcoin and
ultimately came to the conclusion that
Bitcoin was a solution to global QE or
at least that's kind of one of the
context their wish to think about it and
as soon as I connected those dots or as
soon as those two two roads converge to
one both wince I believe Peyman wanted
to get involve full-time in Bitcoin and
ended up joining Unchained capital I
believe their business development
efforts are our business development
efforts but a lot of what I do is write
about that coin in addition to what I
considered my day job at Unchained I
write about Bitcoin I write about
helping people understand how Bitcoin
works how to think about it in the
context of monetary economics but then a
lot of that ultimately feeds back into
what the feds do and it becomes very
topical given the last Grimaud you are
by far one of the more prolific writers
when it comes to this stuff and you got
a way to
what seemingly is highly complex and
almost unconceivable concepts into a
things that everyday people can
understand so we'll give it a go on the
audio side maybe start to just explain
like what exactly is the Federal
Reserve's mandate or X I think starting
there is important people don't really
understand this like why does the Fed
exist yeah so the Fed has a formally the
Fed has a dual mandate one is price
stability and to this full employment
and in the world of the Fed they manage
the money supply of the dollar to
attempt to achieve both of those two
goals essentially you know I think
there's probably some discussion to be
had around what exactly price stability
means but thinking about it as you know
yeah they think about it as those price
of ability of the dollar as well as the
purchasing power of the dollar but then
they also a look at output volatility
then basically that the economy is
consistently growing or seeing growth as
they measure it and then and then
ultimately trying to achieve a level and
I think it's a little bit of a setting
up for failure but trying to maximize
employment in the United States the
active management of the money supply on
it and so as part of that obviously we
saw 2008 2009 they got heavily involved
and started to make a number of
decisions that feels like they went back
in this most recent economic crisis to
the 2008 2009 playbook so maybe just
give us kind of the the two minutes on
like what did they do in oh wait oh nine
and then that'll kind of set us up to
understand what they did here over the
last 12 weeks or so okay you know maybe
maybe to go back even further and then
we'll you know quickly come back to the
crisis because the crisis is really
where you missed the tooth the term QE
respond that really started as
large-scale asset purchases one thing
that I provide conjures the one of the
ways I frame it is they wrote the Fed
has always been doing QE at least since
the 1970s so if you go back and look at
the monetary the base monetary supply of
US dollar in the mid to early 1970s it
was approximately 100 billion dollars
and there was just a steady slope you
know almost you know mechanical or
linear from that period of time mid
1970s to 2007 where the said it
effectively increased the money supply
by 700 percent so effectively from 100
billion to 800 billion just on a very
linear gradual slope and then during the
financial crisis or really what started
as a housing crisis or subprime crisis
have been bled into a banking crisis the
Fed you know if I was to term you did to
define quantitative easing it's just
increasing the supply of dollars it's a
more technical term and what happened in
2008 was that effectively what was a
housing crisis morphed into a banking
crisis that required a much more
aggressive injection of dollars into the
system in in the way that I would frame
it is in order to affect the way to save
the banking system that once the once
the crisis bled from housing to really
the bleeding heart of the US financial
system then it was banks causing other
banks to fail and he runs on bigger
banks causing you know kind of
effectively a knock-on effect and so if
you were to think about over the course
of 35 years or so the Fed had increased
the base money supply by 700 billion
from mid-1970s
to 2007 early 1970s then QE and and
really the height of the liquidity
crisis was September 2008 when Lehman
Brothers failed kind of in the two
months after that period of time the Fed
injected 1.3 trillion dollars so context
30 years 700 billion and then two months
period
1.3 trillion then that you know turned
out to not be enough and the you know
and this is one of my critiques of
quantitative easing is that yeah
if quantitative quantitative easing work
after the financial crisis why did they
need three rounds then we can talk a
little bit about kind of neat
answer but that in many ways just a
rhetorical question
but kind of curious 2008 1.3 trillion
added to the system the economy was
still relatively weak in 2010 in 2011
they then did quantitative easing - or
qe2 they added six hundred billion new
dollars to system they branched out
rather than just buying Treasuries -
buying Treasuries and mortgage-backed
securities to support the housing market
that's that that really is an
interesting hallmark period of time
because you have as qe2 was ending the
European debt crisis was beginning and
the Fed really at the time thought that
they would be unwinding qe2 in early
2012 which we all now know in hindsight
you know I think people who understood
what was happening knew that I was never
realistic but then later in 2012 they
then began what is referred to as QE 3
or QE infinity basically a QE program
that started in the fall of 2012 and and
effectively went on till the end of 2014
and so you know 700 billion being added
over the course of 30 plus years to 1.3
trillion added in the immediate
aftermath of Lehman and in height as the
liquidity crisis - a six hundred billion
dollar you know QE injection over 2010
and 11 and then about 1.7 trillion in QE
3 so all of it can be simplified down to
the Fed inserting dollars into the
system to help prevent a liquidity
crisis and ultimately to help sustain
and over levered credit system and so
how does that play book and kind of the
effects of it or the results lead them
to over the last 12 weeks when we get
this economic kind of shock due to the
coronavirus and the government mandated
shutdown for them to step in so quickly
it feels like this time was much more
firepower much quicker any thoughts
there as to kind of like what they did
and why it felt like it was just kind of
much more urgent than there was song
2008 2009 yeah I would I think I would
probably contribute it
three settings one they had the
experience of 2008-9 and so there's
obviously voices within the fed that are
not just cognizant of the financial
crisis but were active participants in
helping to in their eyes create a
solution in my eyes it's not it just
kicks the can down the road and creates
a larger problem so that's that I think
that's the first piece that they they
lived that world before and if you you
know in 2008 effect with the Fed cut
interest rate seven times and then we
had a liquidity crisis and they injected
1.3 trillion so first and foremost I
think they were seeing a similar type
set up and rather than you know take the
the more measured approach that they had
before they said we have a liquidity
problem this is 2008 we need to do this
now because we can wait but then the
problem is only going to get larger for
ourselves but the other thing is that it
it's important in this we can talk about
mechanically how QE works the reason why
the problem I think is as large as cute
as it as it is today is very much
related to what happened in 2008
so yeah in 2000 the lead up to the
financial crisis there was approximately
52 and half trillion of debt in the
United States and that's not derivatives
that's just as reported by the Fed fixed
liability fixed maturity debt the amount
of cash in the banking system was only
three hundred fifty billion dollars the
total amount of the dollar base money
supply was 800 billion so it was a
massively level financial system and any
time as a system kind of wide event if
that system begins to contract it starts
to feed on itself because it is so
levered so that the the US financial
system can can withstand individual
company's restructuring and can
withstand individual industry's
restructuring like we saw in 2015 with
the oil market it can't sustain a
system-wide deleveraging event because
it effectively just starts to implode on
itself there's no way to reverse course
unless you know things like the whole
system would
we blow up and that's just the scenario
that that that the Fed is unwilling to
totally you know contemplate in the
immediate term to just let let the
system deal ever and so but then the
third thing is when the Fed added three
point six trillion of new dollars to the
financial system through quantitative
easing that induced a massive credit
expansion so said it over the course of
2008 to 2014 out of three point six
trillion few dollars that induced an
expansion of the credit system by 2030
trillion so kind of going into this year
there were 75 trillion of debt in the
United States system and in the banking
system there was just north of two
trillion dollars so each dollar had been
went 35 times approximately and so kind
of on the heels of really I would I
would say three different you know
they're probably all interrelated the
three different events the repo market
breaking in September of 2019 the the
oil market being in material imbalance
again two things that are completely
independent of of kovat and in a
pandemic and then layering on math
economics shut down the the Fed was
staring at a larger problem than 2008
saying 2008 was a credit crisis too much
debt not enough dollars their actions
specifically created a system that had
even more debt and then there you know
reasonably looking down the pipe or the
barrel of an even larger problem than
what set off 2008 in in the combination
of those three things with the
accelerant really being the pandemic and
saying okay well if the size and scope
of QE after the financial crisis was
given it started with something as small
as subprime required as much as we had
to do this these are three things that
are all happening at the same time that
are going to cause the system as a whole
to delever and as soon as that happens
it's going to bleed into the banks and
we have to get ahead of it and we got to
get ahead of it quickly and that's why
they to this point from essentially the
end of February to
this point in time the set is at and
approximately three trillion dollars so
not quite the full extent of you know
five or six years worth of QE after the
financial crisis but in 13 weeks and the
Fed from when the repo market broke in
September 2019 they'd already added five
hundred billion so when you account for
all the money that the feds add added to
the system since last September that
effectively equates to roughly the same
as everything they did in QE one two and
three just in an accelerated timeframe
yeah it's absolutely wild to think about
this and so I want to break down kind of
the impact of these actions right and so
maybe we can break it into short-term
and long-term
I recently tweeted and said well it says
somewhat unpopular opinion in in the
Bitcoin world if you do break it between
short-term and long-term the short-term
impact seems to be doing what they're
optimizing for seems to be working in
their eyes right so you see savings rate
up 33 percent you see personal income
rate 10.5% and some of this is not just
Fed action right some of this also
beefing up of unemployment you see also
of a fiscal stuff that they're doing as
well from the government angle but just
maybe talk through like how do you view
or how would you grade the short-term
impact of the feds actions so far in the
credit in this kind of economic shot
yeah so I think I think that you have to
evaluate in two ways yes evaluate it
from the perspective of what are their
goals and where they attempting to
achieve and are they being successful as
defined by those measures and then I
think you have to look at it from kind
of the long-term consequences of what
what is this fundamentally doing to the
economy and it is it actually creating
larger problems and so the first I would
say what they ultimately are trying to
do so if we go back to the very first
question what is the feds mandate price
stability and full employment in order
for them to
maintain as best they can short-term
employment levels they must sustain the
size of the credit system like that's
what that is what QE is about because if
you live in a world where there's 75
trillion of credit and only two trillion
dollars in the banking system the credit
system is the marginal price set so as a
function of achieving the price
stability mandate which also has a
knock-on effect to the full employment
mandate that there is an implicit
mandate to maintain the size of the
credit system otherwise they couldn't
maintain in their definition price
stability or near-term employment
because if people start to default on
credit and the credit system starts to
collapse upon itself then there's going
to be massive displacement of the
workforce so everything that the all the
actions of the Fed is taking right now
are first to to stabilize the credit
system you know inherently supporting
asset price bubbles because they can't
they can't support the credit system or
stabilize the credit system if they
don't stabilize finance the price of
financial asset so while the Fed doesn't
have an explicit mandate to price target
the S&P 500 or the Dow Jones they have
an implicit responsibility or mandate to
do that via their price the building in
it because I couldn't achieve both as
they did so I would say at least to this
point you could say they're being
successful in in achieving the goals
that they set out to achieve which are
stabilized the credit system now if we
took one step back even not towards the
long-term consequences but the way that
QE works is you get into a system or you
have a system in which the problem is
fundamentally the degree of leverage in
the system and that's why and I won't go
into too much detail now we can talk
about later but in a in a world that
doesn't have such high degrees of
leverage we wouldn't ultimately see the
type of economic disruption
or at least not near the expense of it
should the economy need to shut down for
a month or two it's a function of like
you said very few people having savings
maybe that's improving margin I'll touch
on that but then ultimately the leverage
in times of economic disturbance create
greater problems the economy shuts down
in a way that it can't quickly turn back
on and function that leverage and so but
if you start in the world where there's
too much debt and not enough dollars and
that's a key source of the problem QE
can provide more to others two ways to
solve a credit crisis or credit problem
you can either let credit restructure
basically okay there's too much debt not
enough dollars let's get rid of debt
let's be lever or you can add more
dollars so that existing debt levels can
be sustained if the Fed chooses the
latter every single time the consequence
though is that there's nothing changing
about the market structure so when you
put in those new dollars when I say
first the Fed wants to stabilize the
credit system ultimately this credit
system has to be growing otherwise it's
either growing or contracting and if it
be able to contract and begin to feed on
itself and it walls and they collapse
so first stabilize then grow so as we
look at what happened after 2008 it was
they put three point six trillion
dollars in the system and that generated
23 trillion in new credit so a credit
system that went from 52 point 5
trillion to 75 75 and a half so you have
a debt problem too much debt not enough
dollars you put more dollars in but then
in order for that to quote work the only
way it can is to expand the credit
system so you just get in this vicious
loop of yeah you are sure you are
solving the most immediate problem which
is the credit market was collapsing in
march and by stepping in and the way
that they did they you know did things
that were more extreme that they that
they had even done during kuan you know
post 2008 crisis 2008 crisis they bought
Treasuries and they bought an MBS this
time they're buying Treasuries MBS and
everything under the sun you're buying
corporate bonds directly they're buying
or bond etf they're providing asset
facilities for municipal bonds or
municipal money market funds and so when
you look at the theme it is everything
that they're doing is trying to
stabilize the credit system because it
is so much and so when I when I then
look at that and say yes you are
stabilizing the credit system but then
what are the longer-term consequences of
that it's like oh another way to look at
it is by putting more dollars in the
system you are in a sense deleveraging
the system but only temporarily because
then the wheel starts growing again and
and more debt starts performing and that
was the source of the problem in the
first place now if I was to come back
and look at the savings rate and you
know personal income that the personal
savings rate is a rabbit hole to go down
because like it's almost easier to think
about in a Bitcoin world but I'll start
with dollars do you think like well
there's a certain number of dollars that
exists at the beginning of a year like
like how are you quantifying what the
savings rate is like how are you
determining how what dollars never
actually move because we know each
dollar that you know saved is lent out
many times over so kind of like as a
definition what is it and ultimately
it's like what dollars aren't spent in a
year or at least the way that they
quantify it
I'm dusting off some of the research
that I did kind of three years ago but
it effectively equates or it's very
close to the amount of credit expansion
that happens in the year that because
those are the new dollars and if you
start in January and you end in December
the amount of dollars that weren't spent
or basically the new dollars that are
entered into the system and then the
question as well as that really savings
or what is savings in the / in the first
place because in this period of time the
feds putting more dollars in the system
so are people actually saving it higher
rates or do they now just have more
dollars relative to how you're looking
at at a savings rate whether it's the
dollars divided by GDP and so ultimately
GDP is a function of the expansion of
the credit system as is as is the saving
right so if you are essentially
massively expanding like the private
sector credit system is attempting to
attract right now the Fed is resisting
that by working with the Treasury and
Congress to run massive fiscal deficits
especially in aggregate the credit
system spell expanding well in that
world you're basically manufacturing a
higher savings rate and so it's really
difficult and then at the same time 40
million people are unemployed there's a
lot of uncertainty so natural the
natural inclination is to spend less and
save save more
so is that healthy dislike yes but if
the overall system is actually becoming
less healthy as a function of it then
you know kind of it may feel good in a
month or two months but it's going to
feel really terrible in six months
twelve months five years down the line
and so I think that you know another way
that I frame that like if you think
about the world of Bitcoin cos you know
living in a world of fixed money supply
it's a little bit easier to
conceptualize that if that is there were
21 million bitcoins and that number
wasn't changing what's the savings rate
because everybody's always saving
everyone's always holding that money and
so is it just the just the amount of
Bitcoin that never moves in a given year
as the savings rate because you know
again if money is just intermediating a
series of transactions 100 percent of
all money is always being saved just
just by being saved by a different
person so then you're starting to look
at time horizon and and I think you know
you mentioned before that we get into
the velocity of money but I I think it's
really difficult to look at savings rate
and in velocity when a lot of it's being
manufactured by the very action that the
feds thinking and you can't really use
it as a metric to ascertain the overall
health of the economy yeah this is super
interesting because I Julie said this at
first but but as we know every great
jokes got a hint the truth in it which
was is it really dead if they have no
plan to ever pay it back right and kind
of what we've seen is a just absolute
expansion I think we're at 75 percent
expansion of the Fed's balance sheet
over the last kind of three three and
months and if they were to put it
through this this latest rumor proposal
of another trillion-dollar kind of
infrastructure package or whatever it is
we'd essentially see a hundred percent
growth in a 12-month period of the Fed's
balance sheet so kind of you know is it
actually dead or how do you think about
that balance sheet and kind of the
deficit that just seems to literally
just in 2020 every time I see an
estimation as to what the final deficit
for the year's gonna be it's just
getting bigger and bigger and literally
in some cases has already doubled from
where they thought they were gonna be at
the beginning of the year to now where
they think that remand up yeah so first
every time that I hear a new
trillion-dollar stimulus be announced I
immediately buy that coin
that's my new trigger and I see when we
get to buy Bitcoin every week so no I do
think so
you know realistically and I think I
think you've heated on something really
important because if I had the
opportunity to if I was sitting before
Congress for a member of Congress and I
had chairman Powell
sitting in front of me I would ask him
one question and it is did you or did
you not monetize the debt of the United
States because the answer is clearly yes
and this is something that in my work
going back and reading the transit
transcripts from past Fed meetings from
after the financial crisis in around
2011 I believe it was Richard Fisher who
is the Dallas Fed president
he basically account again I can't quote
verbatim but he made a comment that was
long lines of we need to take the key
lock the door and throw it away on the
idea that we will ever again monetize
the debt of our federal government and
there were a lot of responses that
basically said what we're not monetizing
the debt this is just temporary of
course then Bernanke has gotten on 60
minutes and said and we can remove the
accommodation you know when we need to
and I think there's two problems with it
the first
it's just not true its fault they maybe
believe it to be true but if they
believe it to be true then they don't
understand the consequences of their
actions and and what I mean by that is
if I if I have my very simplistic wheel
it's there's too much debt not enough
dollars through QE the Fed adds more
dollars that creates more debt and then
you get into a world where you have too
much debt again and that's why each time
you know we look at one of these crises
the set is going to have to put more
dollars in to sustain the credit system
because the credit system is now larger
as a function of QE and it's a vicious
cycle and so I think the short answer is
yes we are monetizing debt the
longer-term question or consequence is
how long can that continue because you
have a bunch of children who are
monetary modern monetary theorists that
have begun to think that you know
something that doesn't make any
fundamental economic sense King can go
on forever
and rather than spend the time to
actually understand a fundamental
economics first principle to say okay if
money doesn't grow on trees and and that
you can't just print money then just
because I create more degrees of
separation and put it at the federal
reserve level that it suddenly makes
sense or if it doesn't if that doesn't
make sense on an individual level an
individual balance xi level on a
company's balance sheet level then oh it
makes them at a federal level because
the Fed has this magic power and you say
is it really a magic power or is there
something else that I'm missing that is
causing this system to continue to be
stood up in the interim but maybe just
maybe there's something very naturally
that causes that to break and so you
know when I when I think about debt
monetization the answer is yes or
monetizing debt I define that as you
know at after the end of QE 3 but Fed's
balance sheet was four point five
trillion and I wrote about this in
Ender's Game which says then again could
have could have been Kovac could have
been the next crisis inducing financial
class but that future QE wasn't
inevitable 'ti because of
because of the degree of system leverage
and so when the Fed began to unwind the
balance sheet in 2017 in the fall 2017
they basically slowly took out 700
billion so that they had added three
point six trillion through the process
of QE one two and three and the
definition of if it were truly just
temporary
would have been that they had taken out
all of the three point six trillion they
they didn't even get halfway through QE
3 before the repo market broke in
September and then even before Cova they
added 500 billion so they basically put
back in approximately 75% to 80% of what
they had taken out and now that we're
elevated well above four and a half
trillion which is where the balance
sheet stood after QE 3 it is yes they
monetize the debt they can never they
can never get their balance sheet below
four and a half trillion again because
those dollars are all needed to support
an even more levered financial and so if
if I describe putting dollars in in one
sense of deleveraging the system
basically you've got debt as the the
numerator and dollars as the denominator
if you put more dollars in the
denominator your deleveraging but if
you're taking those dollars back out and
essentially you know reversing the fact
that you've monetized debt then you have
the exact same amount of debt in the
world and you have fewer dollars to
service them so you're actually real
evering the economy as a function of
that operation and eventually in breaks
and you have to put them back in so I
think that there's a reality that while
that is true the amount of debt in the
system and the degree of leverage
actually keeps the system if it's a
precarious balance but it actually keeps
the system together and causes it as a
break at the same time what I mean by
that is that it's actually the high
degrees of leverage that create demand
for dollars so that you can put three
point six trillion dollars in after QE
and still have a world where the dollar
generally holds its purchasing power
because so many people are short them
in many respects the same dynamic exists
today they're setting you know before
the you know March came around there
were 75 trillion of debt two trillion of
dollars so if you put three trillion
dollars in the system from March to
today you're still out of position where
each dollar is owed 15 times and people
are constantly having to demand dollars
and that's keeping debt that's allowing
the dollar despite the fact that a
massive amount of dollars are being
created that is what causes the dollar
to hold its value because so many people
are short of them and so many people
need them now effectively and ultimately
over time you will get into a situation
where that the amount of dollars that
they have to continue to supply into the
system becomes less and less scarce
relative to the amounts of debt and all
while people are opting out and going to
Bitcoin and as people are opting over to
Bitcoin the marginal demand for dollars
becomes weakened or lesser and lesser
over time and once a critical mass of
people are once the density gets high
enough in the Bitcoin where all the
people holding Bitcoin and you don't
have as many people constantly demanding
dollars that's when this cycle of QE
ultimately breaks down where they can't
continue to do it because the dollar
while they're doing it doesn't maintain
its value yeah and so I guess like over
that long period of time historically
we've seen them kind of play this high
wire act rate which is essentially look
at what the debt levels are and either
add or subtract dollars and try to
maintain some level of stability kind of
as their mandate States but really what
you're talking about here is now these
swings or kind of the the volatility of
the problem that they're dealing with is
getting bigger and bigger because
there's more and more leverage right so
you go from kind of hey each dollar is
levered three times five times ten times
50 times you know to whatever it is now
and and so when you see that happening
is there a point in time where the kind
of barrel of the gun they're facing is
such a massive problem that they
literally hit you know the print button
and they create all of these dollars and
they inject them into the system and
they actually overshoot
the target writer or they end up getting
into a place where they've created so
much dollars and put in a system that
that demand can't actually soak it up
right and we end up getting to kind of
high levels of inflation or is that
something that is more of what I would
consider there's a theoretical argument
around high levels of inflation and then
there is the applications that we've
seen in reality in multiple countries
around the world where similar things
have happened but kind of how do you
think about that long-term impact and
what is the likelihood of us getting to
kind of a doomsday scenario from their
perspective yeah so I think that I uh I
believe that day is inevitable I think
that when I think about system leverage
I think about it on a nominal basis and
on a basis that's relative to the amount
of dollars that exists so you know
thinking about it because they are they
are two different problems it's like 75
trillion of debt is a lot of debt now by
the function of QE they're effectively
kind of just over time actually reducing
the amount of debts dollars but there's
also at that same time the problem is
larger so you know in the future you're
going to need to insert more dollars to
support a larger credit and I think that
that's fairly intuitive but you threw
through the course of that I think the
problem is twofold that and we're
already seeing it with with a guy like
Paul Tudor Jones beginning to allocate
Bitcoin right you can put dollars in the
system but you can't make people value
them and the more you know kind of if I
was to summarize the problem that
they're having even in this period is if
the largest has ever been if the
quickest has ever been and the breadth
of it is as wide as it's ever been
they're buying everything under the Sun
and the combination of those three
things is causing people to wake up and
say
this doesn't make any sense and more
people obviously not directly it doesn't
happen overnight but marginally in an
accelerated way people are connecting
the dots between that and Bitcoin and
that over time as people see that the
charade going on that they would say
okay I see that more and more dollars
are being added to the system but you
can't make me values and the same as I
would have yesterday and I'm going to
increasingly convert those to the
Bitcoin or some other monetary medium
and and I think that over you know in
part that with each passing one of these
crises and we don't know you know come
the end of 2021 the Fed's balance sheet
very possibly can be ten trillion
dollars yeah there's no way for the
federal government to run three trillion
dollar deficits without the feds
financing it in some way or the other
and and so kind of part of it is just
the deterioration of the dollar through
just the effectively the distribution of
that through the financial system but
then the other part of it is that well
the financial system as a whole is
massively levered there's people within
the financial system that aren't and
it's the people that aren't that are
generally more productive and that are
generally going to get get ahead of this
sooner than others and those people as
they see this effectively just you know
basically exit you know on the Bitcoin
and increasingly will and then and those
people are people that the Fed system
and the credit system are held together
because people have to demand all as
that becomes less and less true the
efficacy of QE becomes weaker and weaker
their ability to both prop up the credit
system while maintaining the stability
of the dollar will become what you know
less and less probable and less less
effective now I think the bigger they're
like the most the most problematic are
the longer term consequence of this
whole thing is that the action that says
taken today are materially accelerating
the destabilization of the dollar as a
function of that yeah it's not you
again will happen at some point suddenly
but but what I mean by that and in
really the economic principle behind it
isn't just that the feds printing more
dollars two dollars are becoming weaker
it's that the process of QE and Minh and
changing the money supply you know again
it would be less impactful if it was a
lower percentage change or it still
distort the activity to some extent but
that QE it actually fundamentally
changes the economy like if you if you
imagined there's a certain there's a
certain set of people that held dollars
on in March and the people that held
those dollars essentially set market
prices not just in terms of the stocks
and the bonds but in terms of
communicating preferences through price
levels in terms of any consumer good or
housing whatever it may be the Fed comes
in and they double the money supply the
distribution of those dollars is now
significantly different and it
consistently advantages industries that
rely on cheap access to credit so the by
putting more money into the system in
distorting the price of money prices
don't change ratably
and and the money didn't just get into
the hands of people on a perfectly
radical basis and so now you have a
different distribution of people that
are that are pricing and communicating
preferences and that causes ultimately
supply and demand structures first to
change and this is something that Hayek
writes about where he says that it
basically manipulates some supply and
demand structures in such a way that can
only be be maintained so long as more
amounts of money are being injected into
those points of the economy and that
once the rate of that increase stops or
even slows then then everybody figures
out and you have a you have more acute
unemployment that that high degrees and
rapid rates of unemployment are actually
a function of distorting and
manipulating the money supply and that
we are again short term it may feel good
like people's 401ks for you know back up
to close to all-time highs it doesn't
make any
everybody connects that but they're
there and people are feeling better than
this point in time but if the
consequence of that is you're distorting
the entire economic structure of the
country and you're inherently
accelerating the path towards
destabilization of a dollar then what is
the cost of that can't be worse there's
a short-term trade-off and so like I
think about it through that lens and and
people oftentimes think about
hyperinflation as they just printed too
much money and it's not really that it's
it's more so that the printing of the
money distorted the pricing mechanism
and the pricing mechanism distorted the
economic structures and then eventually
you get into a point where the things
that people actually need stops showing
up on shelves and then people feel the
whole function or viability of a
monetary medium fall apart and so that's
where I think I mean yeah I don't I'm
not like a doom and gloom person that's
why I focus on Bitcoin but that but that
I think is the the longer-term
consequence and and each passing episode
of this will require a bigger boat which
only accelerates the dengue yeah one of
the things I've been thinking about I do
not know the answer to this but but is
an interesting kind of framework is
right at the same time that you have
kind of this masking of some of those
pricing functions that you're talking
about you're also gonna get a refocus on
our resilience in the economy rather
than efficiency and so you're gonna get
a lot of kind of supply chains
manufacturing facilities etc right now
it's talk but I think over the next kind
of you know three to five years we'll
sort of see more action of people trying
to bring that stuff back to the United
States and some of they'll be under the
name of national security some of it'll
just be under resilience in general when
they do that obviously it will be less
efficient right so there's actually a
higher cost
that'll be accrued for sure in the short
term over long term maybe they can
replace some of the cost with technology
or something like that but what feels
interesting to me is you've got the
printing of money that masks the pricing
mechanism and at the same time you're
actually gonna end up having a higher
cost of producing certain goods and
services and therefore you're almost
have like this perfect storm to some
degree that is likely to lead to it just
being more difficult there being more
friction to getting some of those goods
on the shelves like you talked about
and because they're printing money it
sounds like you would make the argument
that like it's just harder to see what's
actually happening because there's so
much liquidity in the market is that
fair yeah well I would say that you know
or and it's easier it's easier to think
about the consequences in micro examples
so and I'm not I'm not trying to also
then translate this into every sector of
the economy but you know I go to my
local barbecue joint and the price of
beef is now 33 percent more expensive
for brisket 33 percent more expensive
than it was you know three months ago
and I'm looking at that and be like hmm
I'm gonna now change my behavior they
had to change their behavior but yeah
I'm not gonna go get to see all our
lunches you know so the everybody has to
respond and they're not just responding
to changes in core underlying economic
preferences they're having to figure out
what the change in preferences actually
are of market participants versus what
is just a function of more dollars gains
and and and in a perfect world and
that's why bitcoin is the perfection of
a monetary medium there is no change in
the money supply so any change in price
is more clearly a direct communication
of a change in preference and so I think
when you're speaking to and I do think
that this will be the healthy outcome of
the of the pandemic it might not be a
healthy outcome of the the feds response
to it but that it is that people will
look to make their supply chains more
redundant they'll move to localize more
things that are critical to say you know
can we be exposed to to a world where
pharmaceuticals are you know over
overwhelmingly like regardless of the
fact that it's China just on on any
trading partner and it could be if you
looked at it on a hyper localized way
it's not just like yeah it may be kind
of build more globally in the interest
of national you know crap national
interest but more realistically and when
I'm thinking about you know
reading about the the taiko or Tyson
Foods plants being shut down I've got a
local food supplier that has local farms
in Texas you know making sure you know
it's like so people are going to people
are going to change things in ways that
just create greater resilience I think
that's positive I think that there's
also a question as to if there wasn't
price manipulation in the market to
create an appearance that we have a lot
of time or that you know we're solving
the short-term problem and we can kick
off dealing with the problem so to the
future that what what what system heals
faster the one where people kind of feel
the pain immediately and then have to
actively work to you know pull
themselves up by the bootstraps or one
where they can then be the boiling frog
because you know in my world and I think
this the problem that the Fed has yeah
and I wish I had the quote in front of
me so that I could read it verbatim but
um Bernanke in 2011 at a quote when when
they were kind of coming to the tail end
of qe2 and the European debt crisis was
ensuing where he basically admitted like
I know I can't solve this problem
through monetary policy and that there
are fiscal and structural problems that
can't be solved by the Fed but we have
to do something to be palliative like
they the Fed single-handedly not to
Annalee the Fed almost uniformly has an
idea that we have to do something rather
than nothing and again if it feels like
it's okay in the context when you remove
several degrees of separation from
actual economic reality but imagine that
was a company that was just bleeding
cash and you were an individual and you
were like oh okay I'm gonna give you
another hundred million dollars and and
they didn't change anything you know and
you're like oh they just lost another
his own the others I'm gonna give him
another you eventually you would stop
doing that because there was a real
economic consequence to it in the feds
world they're doing things in a reactive
way because they ultimately only have
one tool and that's increasing the money
supply and I would say that actually in
action that they could take is not doing
anything and that would actually result
in it may result in greater short-term
pain but just be
to some of you know the idea that you
were talking about that may change as a
function of pandemic it would cause
people to react in a much quicker way
that they likely would have done that
anyways but when it when it becomes a
shorter leash or a shorter fuse then
they actually miss survival instincts
have to kick in quicker and then you
know so it's not something necessarily a
matter of you know are there some
positives to come I believe that there
will be but it's like well wouldn't
there have been positive to come if the
Fed didn't do this too and maybe they
would have happened in a more
accelerated timeframe
I mean basically your example of like
hey a company's one hundred million
dollars why were you giving them more
right and if they don't change anything
I think you could also say it's like
where are they putting the money is a
huge piece of this as well so one
creating the money is a problem because
you're giving it kind of the entire
economy but but to also if you look just
at the bailouts right just those
specifically I mean quite literally in
some cases that's what they were doing
they were finding companies that had
previously been bad capital allocators
and they gave him more money right in
many cases didn't change the executive
team didn't do anything and so I think
that this framework of kind of like if
it's not working
money just throwing money the problem
may not solve it can be applied both on
an economy level but also in a number of
cases where they chose to actually put
the money right and it feels like at
least my perspective has been like I
don't want you to print the money but if
you're gonna print it or we actually put
her off just giving it right to the
people like forget buying all these
assets forgetting you know giving you
the corporation stuff like why not just
go and take three trillion dollars and
just hand it right to people right does
that actually solve some of the problems
or does that make it worse well I think
you know two things I would say there
first I think is I think if you said
pulled it back up to thinking about the
Fed as a company it would be like you
guys keep doing this and it doesn't
solve the problem so why do you keep
doing it you know like what thank you if
you were if you did have the temperament
of a board member for a fortune 500
company you looking at your own actions
would have some introspection and say
okay maybe there's a different approach
to this whole thing
and they just
get there but then I think the second
question is I I would say that the
problem is more directly all of the
allocation starts with a FET so think
about you know 20 trillion dollar
economy in the United States with two
trillion dollars in the banking system
and two trillion dollars are being held
by yeah depending on how you look at it
250 million people excluding you know
people who are under 16 or so and and
then suddenly you have 12 people sitting
around a room saying okay this is how
we're going to spend three trillion
dollars in the course of 33 months
right those people even if they're even
if they were each individually and I
hate using the example because Warren
Buffett doesn't understand Bitcoin but
even if they were you even if a Warren
Buffett was each person sitting at the
Fed and you suddenly said hey dude
here's three trillion dollars figure out
the best way to divvy that out that
would ultimately be a very bad outcome
because Warren Buffett as you know
revered and smart as he is again despite
the fact that he doesn't get Bitcoin
he's like he doesn't the people that
actually make up an economy possess
knowledge that individual actors never
could and they they understand not only
what their preferences are but then they
also understand what our customers
preferences are somebody's sitting in a
room at the Fed allocating that much
capital can't possibly have your perfect
information or near as much information
as the market does and so it doesn't
matter you know how you're allocating it
or who's allocating it or to whom it's
that you're fundamentally distorting the
the entire purpose of money in
communicating prices and communicating
information through price signals by the
fact that a very few number of people
are categorically changing the game I
think in one of my posts I equated to
it's not like moving the goalposts it's
basically like building the football
field on a 1980s tile waterbed
then shifting the goalposts like that
the ground underneath everybody just
shook and if you in many ways it
paralyzes the entire market like right
now there is no market function of price
and risk everybody who and again there's
always exceptions rules but anybody
who's buying the stock market right now
is not doing it because they're
underwriting risk and pricing the risk
of an asset they're doing it because
they believe that the Fed is going to
cause the prices to go up and and and
what does that do that inherently
introduces moral hazard and and when you
have high degrees of moral hazard and
markets then you're and a big function
of it is bailouts from the Fed then you
know you just you can't harmonize an
economic structure so long as that's
going on so I I think into certain ways
you could say you know if you put a
better group of people together that
were allocating the money like maybe you
get marginally better outcomes but
there's a problem
fundamentally with the operation itself
and it can't be solved by you know
changing that the people that you give
it to or changing the people who are
doling the money out it's actually the
the fact that you know a small number of
people just don't possess information
and the fundamental consequences is
distorting the underlying price and
mechanism of the conduct of an economy
yeah so you've written an entire series
basically gradually and then suddenly
and you're specifically speaking I think
about Bitcoin but but do the issues that
the Fed continues to kind of expand do
those happen in the same manner like is
there almost a correlation between these
two assets between Bitcoin and the
dollar where we have a kind of gradually
than suddenly collapse of the dollar at
some point and that coincides with a
gradually and then suddenly rise of
Bitcoin to some global reserve status
yeah so I think that I think the first
thing to recognize is that they the two
stories are inherently intertwined there
are two competing forms of money they're
two competing
ultimately economic systems one spawning
one
redlining in that we have in a
simplified way one way that I describe
it is when a Bitcoin is traded for
dollars the exact same amount Bitcoin
exists in the exact same amount of
dollars like this the market is just
communicating a preference as to which
form of currency it would rather hold
and a price of Bitcoin going up over
time is more and more people signaling
that they would rather hold Bitcoin than
dollars and that what that effectively
represents is more and more people on
the margin opting out in an increasing
way from the dollar system and that's a
problem for the dollar system because it
reduces the marginal demand for dollars
and again the Fed and any government
they can control the supply of their
money but they can't make people value
and so I think that also if you think
about Bitcoin adoption and you know how
is it that today at least and I think
the space is going to evolve over time
naturally as more and more people hold
it there will be more direct commerce
from that point but today the principle
way that people get Bitcoin is trading
it for some amount of via well how do
you get Fiat you generally sell a
financial asset you know when someone's
thinking about buying a Bitcoin maybe
they're going to sell their stock or
maybe they're going to sell their
response and so the actual transition
over to Bitcoin will induce in my view
it will accelerate the essentially the
propensity of the credit system to want
to contract or collapse which will
induce the rate at which that that has
to do QV and will also reduce the
effectiveness of that key so I think
that it's you know have two sides of the
same coin
and Bitcoin and at least in my view is
and there's a market signal that's
telling us this it you know in its price
being that that it's winning and it's
going to continue to win as a function
of six 21,000,000 supply on one side and
QE endlessly or at least intermittently
and an increase in fashion on the other
side but that you know when the coup
when the question is will does a dollar
class gradually or suddenly it's
collapsing gradually right now
I think you know it you know it's also
one of those ideas where people key in
on bitcoins volatility they say it's not
a bad story value but then they look at
the chart of purchasing power of $1 and
it's just a gradual demise and so I
think and just you know it's impossible
to predict wouldn't because confidence
is a very fragile thing the dollar as a
system is based on trust bitcoin is not
and and so there's a question as to when
the confidence in the dollar really
breaks and I think that you will know
that when it happens and when it happens
it doesn't go back in the back you know
like the cats out of the bag doesn't go
back in and I would point to an example
of like Argentina now in some places
this that's not quite at a
hyperinflation but if you go back I
think 12 to 24 months ago you can look
at the point on the chart when
confidence was broken in the Argentine
peso and you know if the currency
basically collapsed 50% in you know a
very short period of time and now it's
collapsed 90% you know effectively
they're somewhere they're around where
it's like you will know when it happens
and it will happen quickly but you don't
go from you know trust or confidence in
a currency being lost to overnight
hyperinflation
that there that that even beyond there
there is a process but the point that
the breaking point you should be able to
be kind of read as readily known now
again not everybody's going to know it
right most people don't know the fact
that the feds printed three trillion
dollars nope you know the vast majority
of people and this is one of the reasons
why what the feds doing is so pervasive
visit most people don't ever learn about
the feds action until they show up at
the grocery store and their meat is more
expensive or they go to the bar and
their beer is more expensive or they're
taking health care and the health care
is more expensive they like the way that
most everyone including myself since I'm
not like I'm you know just because I
know about what's happening at the Fed
then I have a perfect prediction of
knowing what my food is going to cost
the grocery store I have a general idea
that it's going to cost more in dollar
terms
but that the way that most people learn
of information is through prices and so
you know in the in reality kind of we'll
look at a time where like the price of
Bitcoin will just break the dollar at
some point in the future and the people
that are paying attention to bitcoin
they'll see it and they'll know it the
people that are not yet moved over to
the new economic system they're gonna
figure it out because their dollars that
they still hold purchase less in terms
of real guns and I do think that that
that does at some point happen in a very
in a way that is identifiable but it
also isn't you know going from or
something to the arrow yeah and it feels
like as this is happening some of my
favorite charts to look at are like the
stock market denominated in dollars and
the performance and then if you do
nominate the same thing in Bitcoin right
I mean literally it's the exact opposite
direction than it was nominated in
dollars if you look at other asset same
thing and so it feels as if there is a
marketing campaign right in an indirect
way that the Federal Reserve is really
running because you're able to highlight
kind of a very separate approach the
world one is you said it's kind of
unlimited QE based inflation driven
dollars the other is this fixed limited
supply I guess the question then becomes
at what point does a government reach of
the game theory moment of the people are
already moving they're opting into this
fixed supply asset how did they navigate
that is that just one day they all get
together in a meeting and they're like
look let's move off the inflation system
into a Bitcoin system is it something
that looks more like hey why don't we
actually take some of this Bitcoin stuff
and put it into our our treasury like
how do you think about the nation-states
as this kind of moves from a gradual
thing to a suddenly thing and how they
kind of have to navigate that the
transition yes so I think that you know
one of the one of the first things I
think that certain you know we've
already seen members of Congress call
for people to ban Bitcoin because
they're already connecting the dots that
Bitcoin challenges the dollar and I
think
the vast majority people think that
that's still crazy that the bitcoins up
180 billion dollar assets served in I
think that's purchasing power but it
still can't the cute shy neon jecht it's
just a toy and this so volatile but yes
the toons clearly changed in just the
last couple of years
sound for for central bankers and
specifically chairman Powell made a
comment to say I can see how private
money could have a role in the future
but I think that you know the first
clear market that is becoming a real I
think there's just probably a
psychological impact that's just the
value of Bitcoin and I get yeah it's
impossible to predict where that is but
it's probably when Bitcoin is north of a
trillion dollars that that creates a
psychological this is not something that
we can just continue to ignore and then
I think on the other side there there is
a reality that the mere existence of
Bitcoin will make the operation of QE
less and less effective and and both of
those two factors will cause people to
have to deal with that coin in some form
or fashion I think that there's one camp
of people that say well they'll just ban
Bitcoin and we can go back and we
promise we'll stop printing dollars or
go back to a gold back monetary system
and I don't think that's realistic I
think it's I think it's less realistic
because it doesn't give them enough
credit I think that they will you know
people at the Fed will look at Bitcoin
they will get smarter on it people in
Congress will get smarter on many people
in Congress will own Bitcoin and what
they'll ultimately try to do is try
they'll try to in in in more ways than
one
probably co-opted Network which I again
I don't think will be successful but
they'll create tighter restrictions on
their visibility into the network of you
know how how bitcoins being traded or
move kind of increased reporting
requirements I think I do think at some
point that you know the will basically
change the tax rules and yeah they'll
say okay everybody who's in the United
States again this is specific United
States but it's probably a playbook for
for any government will say we're going
to accelerate your cap gains taxes on
Bitcoin pay that into the Treasury and
we're going to capitalize the government
via that mechanism and thereafter any
Bitcoin track transactions not taxable
like that seems like realistic and
plausible yet at least thinking in their
mind solving tubers and once known I
have this thing that's actually
functional is money now people demand it
I need some of that to be able to fund
my government and how do i you know I
could either do this 6102 gold ban which
again I think would be infinitely harder
to enact or or operationalize and in you
know the context of Bitcoin and so as
they're thinking about those 4d chess
moves where they're like okay if I do
this if I come out and I just try to ban
Bitcoin does that just fuel the fire and
cause it cause my system to collapse
more quickly and cause that system to
become less controllable and that once
they you know kind of continue to to
work through all the different scenarios
are like well maybe I should just
accelerate cap gains taxes capitalize
myself and then save the trade-off and
you get to that is that I'm basically
just pulling forward your taxes but
they're after all your Bitcoin
transactions are not taxed so I think
that I think that they're going to
increasingly have to deal with that but
I think it will principally be function
of bitcoins price and bitcoins price is
a function of adoption which is also a
positive side that you know more people
will have it at that point in time so
it'll be harder and harder to you know
regulate away and the people within
Congress or legislators all over the
world will take the route of taxing and
reporting rather than causing their
problem to become larger by the last
question for you is round gold
how does gold play into all of this oh
man I I don't like go out of my way to
[Music]
diss gold but I can just tell I can
speak from my own experience I think
that bitcoin is an order of magnitude
better than monetary medium than gold I
thinks it
current disaster that is our Fiat system
is the manifestation of gold's failure
basically the Fiat system was built on
top of gold and then was ultimately able
to be detached from gold and the only
reason that was possible to happen was
because there was a limitation and goal
of the monetary medium and that prior is
a Bitcoin existing gold was still a
better form of money than the dollar but
then in certain ways now the Bitcoin
exists it's almost a worse form of money
than the dollar because it's easier to
convert dollars in the Bitcoin and I
think that I think that there will be
some period of time obviously the market
is the market people have their own
perspectives and there's there will be
asymmetry of information and it's not
suddenly that that that gold exists has
the same or that the implications for
gold are not necessarily in the same
time horizon the same or the operations
are a Bitcoin are not the same for gold
as they are for fear but the long-term I
believe that that is to be true there is
there is some kind of floor value and
gold in an industrial production but I
think what will happen is that Bitcoin
will de monetize gold and that the
monetary premium that existed in goal
which is its primary reason for holding
it will go away and I think I think the
difficult thing for people then that
owned gold is that they were 100% right
on the problem of the Fiat system but I
think what they missed was that there
was a limitation of gold that allowed it
to exist and the Bitcoin came along and
solved those limitations and that the
people that owned gold are the type of
people that are looking for hard money
and that they're the people that are
most likely on the early curve of the
probably the next wave of people to
connect and get over the fact that
Bitcoin isn't physical and recognize
that the properties that they actually
bought schools for learn are in Bitcoin
but their improved on a number of
accounts and I would say that in the
terms of Bitcoin has perfected scarcity
so there is some large
inflation of the the supply of gold and
that Bitcoin is basically combining
scarcity with the ability to teleport
over a communication channel which is
inherent limitation of gold which caused
this to naturally be centralized which
which created risk for the length of the
Fiat monetary and so I think in the
short period of time people are going to
buy gold cuz it's you know the default
flight to safety but over any longer
time horizon or even if I was looking at
a year or two years or three years the
the value of gold and Bitcoin terms as
with other assets will continue to
decline but there will be more of a
direct V monetization that occurs
between gold and Bitcoin just as will
occur between dollars or any fiat and
they cool and ii think you're right to
think you're very very right where where
can people go find you on the internet
or find out more about unchanged capital
yeah so that's the two places to find me
are on twitter
parker a lewis or at parker a lewis and
then on on our website they people can
go learn about unchained at unchained
- capital calm and you mean they have
around bitcoin we can help and i release
all the things that i write news about
on the unchain capital walk so unchained
- capital calm and twitter Parker a
Lewis and that need you to find awesome
before I forget is there was there a TV
show Parker Lewis can't lose that they
were all tweeting about their there was
a TV show called Parker Lewis can't lose
I think I would think he came out he
came out in 1990 it was different
knockoffs of their sewers day off and so
I often used to get you know asked I've
named after the show but I did predate
the show when when I saw much people
tweet about that I what the hell is this
thing and then I saw somebody said
something about ask him some you know
about the share when everyone's like I
guess there was something so I awesome
and listen I appreciate you doing this
like I said you by far one of the most
prolific writers around Bitcoin in
what's going on in the world
so just keep it up your your educate a
lot of people and link to everything and
with this again
yeah problem you know I really
appreciate you having me on I always
enjoyed the conversation and hopefully
once things open back up we'll get you
back down to Texas they're all I'll get
up to New York and we can be get where
we can go out to Wyoming